thank you as chair of the house ways and
means committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of covert 19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to
order 2020-04 public body is authorized
to meet electronically
this is a revenue work session please
note that there is no physical location
for members of the public to observe
and listen contemporariously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporarily
during this meeting to the zoom
electronic platform
and the public has access to
contemporaries listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available on the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with the house rules rsa
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting
should call 271 3600
or email hces at lake dot data
dot us in the event the public is unable
to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled i want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting to assist
us
christopher shea and jennifer fall
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's stop the meeting by taking on roll
call attendance
when each member state states their
presence please also state whether there
is anyone in the world review
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know
law so represent bernstein
it's february 16th it's 9 00 a.m year
we'll begin roll call with
representative patrick abrami
representative mary griffin
representative griffin representative
owery
present alone at home representative
ober representative ober
representative ducette fred doucette
you'll be late okay representative
berstein is your clerk today
and i'm in my home in nottingham new
hampshire in my home office by myself
representative bob ellie balom new
hampshire president and my wife is in
the bedroom
representative john genningen home
sale in new hampshire wife and daughter
are in the house
representative herschel nunes good
morning representative thank you i am at
home
inside my house and it's pouring down
rain
goodness representative baxter
thank you representative i'm home alone
and it's also
pouring pretty bad outside but your hair
still looks terrific
representative spillsberry homie
cheryls down my wife elsewhere in the
house
representative paul tudor
representative almighty i'm alone
in lebanon and we've got a sleet drizzle
that's been going on for hours
representative richard ames yes i'm here
in jeffrey in my home office alone
representative southworth here alone
in dover and representative malloy
has not yet joined us i understand he'll
be late representative schamberg
representative schamberg here returning
from concord at 28 miles an hour
you're muted yes i realized that i'm
here alone in randolph where it's
snowing and blowing hard
representative go marlow aaron swansea
alone
representative laughman representative
thomas laughman
representative gorg good morning i am
here and alone
representative mary hacken phillips good
morning i am present for my home
in hanover alone with my two dogs
representative murphy good morning i'm
here in hanover as well in my home
office alone
good morning representative major good
morning i'm here in my home
office and my wife is in the house
mr chair at the moment there are 17 of
us present
six of us are absent but i understand
some will be late and i'll update
accordingly
on i'm i'm kind of here hey
all right i'm alone i'm not i'm home and
stratum uh my wife's in the house
i'm actually trying to attend the uh
chairs meeting at the same time
i'm having trouble getting through so
i'm on the phone i'm on the phone i
can't get through on my zoom
so i'm on the phone with them but
nothing started okay
yep we can't be in two places at the
same time so pat
volunteered for the uh vice chairman
chairman's meeting uh before we start
janine
do you have a recommendation for the
members
oh i was speaking earlier that it it
would be helpful
if you've raised your hand and you're in
the queue to unmute yourself so you'll
be ready to go
you know we'll save a few seconds here
there and also if you could lower your
own hand
i i can pay better attention actually
and it will just be easier from norm to
to know who really has their hand raised
if i miss it
okay we have a busy morning
let's start off with the lottery
commissioner
commission which is charlie mcintyre
the executive director uh discussing the
sports betting
is mr mcintyre here
he is rep seven major along with a mr
maloney so they're both available to
speak to you
also i sent to the committee this
morning um a powerpoint
it's actually a pdf file that i
converted but it's uh charlie's gonna
put it up on the screen i think but i
and it's just related to sports betting
a a document if they would
i don't know if you see the front of
this it's all yellow
and when you're printing from home that
we uses up an
awful lot of yellow right
so if there was the same color
for charts fine but when they take the
whole background
we'll try to encourage that going
forward represent major
so charlie if you want to share your
okay great good morning everyone this is
charlie mcintyre
um executive director of new hampshire
lottery and with me um
today is our director of sports betting
danny maloney
um and i think you folks have questions
related to revenues related to sports
betting particularly as relates to
the super bowl of a couple of weeks ago
or a week and a half ago so
i'm going to go through only a few
slides there's only a handful
i apologize for the yellow ink i won't
do that again certainly not when i'm not
handing them out to you
and so mr chairman i'll go through the
slides
and then if you have questions if you
can save them to the end because some of
the slides might answer the questions
this is a chart of the revenues
related to new hampshire lottery sports
betting by month
for calendar year 2020. we launched
december 30th
of 2019 so obviously december of 19 with
not have meaningful revenues because it
was basically a day and a half
so this is our first year of revenue and
i'll go through the definitions
left to right obviously month means the
calendar month
handle means the amount of wagering the
lottery
took in during that month so if
representative major about 50
on the patriots and i bet fifty dollars
on the chiefs
that would be a hundred dollars ggr
stands for gross gaming revenue which is
the amount left over
after all of the wagers have been paid
off that won
so this in large terms is the gross
profit
the lottery and the draftkings
realize hold
is a function of the percentage
of revenue that the lottery and
draftkings keep
as a percentage of the wagered amount
and so what that means is
if we paid out ninety dollars out of a
hundred dollars bet
the hold would be ten percent if that
makes sense to everyone
and then the final column is the state
revenue
as you can see the hold which is the
amount we keep as profit
varies dramatically month by month
and so for example in some months we
were below five percent
and in some months we're above 10 and
that's a factor and that's a function of
all of the various events that happened
in a given month
and whether the folks who want them who
bet on them won or lost
um we would expect the hold over the
course of a year to be somewhere between
six and eight percent
seven percent being the middle obviously
we would submit that
in you know this past year was not a
normal year by any stretch and still
quite literally isn't so our revenues in
march
through july were significantly lower
than we would anticipate
for sports betting so look at the handle
three million dollars is a very low
number for a month because
in the month of april there wasn't much
sports to bet on
you know all of the leagues cancelled
their events college
cancelled their events um there are a
number of events that are large in the
calendar for example like the
ncaa basketball tournament would have
been during that april the final games
would have been very large
didn't exist so in this year
2020 calendar year the state profited 11
million dollars
and our original revenue estimates were
10 million dollars
in a full calendar year all events and
so
going forward we would anticipate uh to
exceed that figure the original 10
million dollars we had estimated when
sports betting was launched
and if we go to the next slide
so this for example is a the top five
events
in the month of january by how much the
state profited
meaning folks bet on an event
and because they bet on the side that
lost to a large extent
the state profited so the same terms
apply handle gross gaming revenue and
hold
and as you can see lots of folks bet on
the seahawks
i think it was the cx to beat the rams
uh danny is that right
uh yes yeah and so the state profited a
great deal and so
these are our five largest events by the
mount the state profited
obviously the college football clemson
lost to ohio state
that was quite good for the state and on
down
and every month these events vary by
type
in some months they'll be college
basketball and
obviously during football season
football tends to be larger
and so those are the five events for
example
in january by state win and then these
are the five
by state laws and so as you can see
you have very large events and this one
for example mr brady
q keeps winning um and a lot of folks
here obviously have
fondness for mr brady mr gronkowski a
lot of folks
uh wagered on the timothy buccaneers in
january and
were rewarded by significant winnings
um and so that led up to obviously uh
the super bowl
in in february 7th um
and one of the things about the
buccaneers winning was
they weren't supposed to win in fact
they weren't supposed to get out of the
first round of the playoffs but
because they were not favored the odds
were
significantly greater than they would
have been had they been a favorite team
so
for example you see the bottom of the
screen there it says future
buccaneers to win the nfc championships
the amount wagered was only 41 000
but we paid off at 130 000 because the
odds were so
against them they weren't supposed to
win uh their packages were favored by a
significant amount
but this is the good news
so this is sports betting by state
calendar year 2020
in our first year of operations when you
run across the same terms
handle gross gaming revenue hold and
state revenue
we're third per capita in the country in
our first year of operations
um and the other states are fall off
the super bowl um while our liability at
one point prior to
the game was three million dollars
because there was a significant
amount of wagered activity um wagering
at the end
on the kansas city chiefs the total loss
for the game
ended up as 1.7 million and it is likely
we will actually break even or
have a little profit for february going
forward based on
the month and so singular events can
skew
it briefly but over the course of a year
it's exceedingly profitable for the
state
and i think we have done better than
expected well
i don't think we did we did better than
expected um
and amongst our comparators even though
we're brand new at this
we're number three in the country per
i guess mr chairman that was my brief um
slideshow and i guess any questions once
again more colored ink i'm sorry
but um i'll leave whichever slide up you
want
and i'll happily answer questions as
chairman members of the committee
okay questions from the committee it was
a great presentation
uh questions from members
uh representative jamal can you
thank you can you describe uh explain
the hold again for me please certainly
it's a percentage of
our profit which is gross gaming revenue
as against the handle which is the
amount wagered
so really in business terms it would be
our gross profit
and we split that 50 50 with draftkings
without offset for promotions but it's
hi hi charlie thank you um
so we know a lot of the betting is is
from massachusetts
um i don't know if you have the exact
split of how much is from mass but
are you sensing anything in the in the
massachusetts legislature
that may make sports betting legal there
in the near future
yes certainly as we do our revenue
estimates here certainly to your
question the answer is yes
um the vast majority of our betting
activity
is on mobile and that's 90 percent from
in-state
88 from mid-state the majority of our
physical locations are from out-of-state
for massachusetts specifically
uh and that's at the brook in seabrook
um
i do know that there is a there is
activity in the state house of boston
for sports better one of the
difficulties there is there are so many
stakeholders that are fighting each
other
i would imagine it'll be difficult for a
bill to come out i would expect one to
come out
one of the things there that i don't
worry about so much
is their physical locations are likely
to be in everett
and springfield and plainville nowhere
near our border
so there's that secondarily i would
imagine i don't i haven't seen the law
yet i would imagine that their
wagering activity would be subject to
taxation
and we would have an immediate six
percent advantage because we don't take
state income taxes and mass does
and so the wager in mass would be
benefited
six percent by driving to new hampshire
so certainly as relates to our revenue
estimates we don't
we don't make a change based off of it i
don't expect it to be certainly the next
year
uh the following year possibly but um
i don't i wouldn't lower it but
certainly representative brahmy
that's a quick follow-up how about any
rumblings in maine
uh there are rumblings in maine yes but
nothing substantive and the governor
seems opposed to it so and she vetoed a
bill last time
okay thank you would you send us an
email relative to the data you just gave
us
relative to mobile versus fixed
locations
those are interesting percentages
certainly
thank you mr chairman on
can you give us a description or send us
a description of how you find
the people who have been betting on
um in very large amounts the ones that
you
decided to define as problem problem
gamblers
and what what you do once you've
identified them
um i can't danny
right so we're what we're looking at in
terms of uh
problem gaming activity it's not
necessarily the amounts um because
obviously there are people of
of high means that can bet you know very
very high amounts in a game
without a problem uh the way that the
problem gaming
uh works on draftkings system is they
have
uh user controls where a user can kind
of set limits
for either day month week however they
want to kind of limit their play
and they also have the ability through
algorithms where if a person is betting
um i guess the term be like chasing
losses if a person is
escalating they keep betting higher and
higher um
it kind of sets off a flag uh for
for the for the system in the system
that when they call in
draftkings can kind of give them
information like here's the national
council from problem gaming
i hear these new these tools you have if
you want to limit your play
so it's kind of it's you can't really do
it on an amount it's it's hard to do
it's kind of because it's all relative
to the person
but there are tools within the system
that a person can preemptively prevent
themselves from having a problem
and there are algorithms that run that
look for certain activity that a player
is doing
that would make draftkings need to reach
could i follow all right sure
follow up thank you so this this is
dependent on draftkings
on doing things and there are
algorithms such as the one about betting
more and more and more uh increasingly
and and you send them to regular
national
helplines
correct uh draftkings and i'm sorry
sorry
and i was um told before that
on mr mcintyre would be
going to to his friend in massachusetts
to ask if they
studied how useful this was
i i did representative elmi um
i actually emailed the exchange with
marlene warner who is the head of mass
council on problem gambling
i had forwarded previously um the
resources she had
directed me towards um to one i think a
committee staff member but i can forward
it along to you directly if you want
i said that email probably 10 days ago
thank you i don't think i just i didn't
see that email
okay today directly then if that's okay
thank you very much
yeah mr chairman if i could introduce
danny uh if you give us background for
10 seconds
yes oh hello uh so i am i'm
an attorney uh is in my uh past life
uh i'm now uh i just received an llm
from unlv
in gaming law and regulation i started
with the lottery in august
extremely excited to be here so i've
been really studying
uh different types of uh casino gaming
sports betting obviously was the big
focus
because of the the repeal that happened
a couple years ago by the supreme
court uh so i kind of came out of the
program
and got right to the lottery and and
it's been uh been a pretty smooth
transition since
you know we really hit the ground
running in new hampshire
thank you thank you uh representative
bernstein
thank you mr chair hey all things
considered charlie and danny
you guys had a fantastic year uh so
congratulations on that
my question has to do with the imbalance
when uh
too many bets are placed on team a
instead of team b
and exposing the state to some liability
couldn't you go out of state and place a
bet
to even it out so it's 50 50. is that
two in your arsenal
and if it is let me hear you thinking
about why or why you wouldn't
do such a thing um i i don't think it is
it would require me
taking money from the state treasury and
betting in another state
um which i think would be an issue um
i'm just thinking
um honestly
there's two ways to do this there's
actually changing the odds the problem
with changing the odds is you're going
to get
folks who are experienced bettors what
we call sharps
who chase lines who actually look for
line movement
and better accordingly and what that
does is it really benefits
experienced sharp betters at the expense
of
casual players and so what really what
you have to do in this regard and have
to
you know you have to set the line
correctly
and just you know root against the
buccaneers
you know that's all there is to it and
and hope because that
at the end of the day you want folks to
have the experience was supposed to have
and
we tried to mimic this as against the
illegal market
so the illegal bookmaker sets odds and
lives
and breathes by wins and losses and so
we didn't want to have a
a market which was overly beneficial to
the state because that really
is to the detriment of the player base
you know what i'm saying
like if you look i still like delaware
where the hold is 19
that's not a product that's going to be
survived it's going to survive long
because folks who play are going to know
i'm losing 9 of my bet to the state i'd
rather go someplace else
and so what we want to have is a
competitive product in the marketplace
and so
yes we danny actually did up a mock
diagram of
if we took half a million dollars and
went to delaware or rhode island
um but you know ingest obviously we
okay thank you charlie uh
represented murphy thank you i just had
a question about the um
percent split with the hold is that
50 50 across the united states or and
how is that number or that split
negotiated
it fails wildly by state the new
hampshire way we do things is now called
the new hampshire model
which is really the state controls the
function and profits directly from it
whereas a state like nevada which is
where danny came from
they just regulate it like it's they're
selling bagels
and it's a very very low percentage of
state receives like you look at nevada's
number
that did four billion dollars of waging
activity in 2020
and they only kept 17 million of it um
ours is by contract and so it's a 50 50
split
with a uh allowance for marketing and
promotions that we give to draftkings to
sort of
promote to the player base so it ends up
being around
45 percent i think
yeah this question is about uh sports
books here in new hampshire
locations and the the question of
limiting those locations that came up
around
that other bill we were looking at i
don't remember its number
and during that discussion i
i asked for follow-up information
about the specific to the
uh sports books that have been set up
and
i think uh contract information and
whatever would help us all
better understand what we're talking
about
yeah that was part of the same email
representative ames thank you for the
question i'd forward it along
i'll read forward again if that's okay
yeah it must have missed the vote
somewhere
i don't know like i said because i
collected that the contract data the
towns that voted for it uh the resources
i received from marlene
mass council of problem gambling so i'll
forward that along again
yes nice presentation thank you for the
betting mobile betting that occurs out
of state do you
so everything in state is placed in
state if you were a resident of mass
and placed a bet here you're on your own
taxes in massachusetts
uh how you file there or what you comply
with is up to you we don't
obviously withhold on the for other
states um
but i i like i said you have to be in
state to bet
and so there's no income tax in the
state so we don't um
thank you charlie chairman thank you
members of the committee good to see you
all
next we have the department of revenue
uh lindsey stepp
commissioner melissa rollins senior
financial analyst
and devin rogers group financial analyst
so chris are they here they're here
representative
major it's um carolyn lear is here in
place of uh
representative excuse me commissioner
step
okay
good morning committee members can you
hear me
yes we said all right great
so we were invited to come on to speak
to you concerning some outstanding
questions you had
um and i'll just tick through the
questions if that works and then we can
ask any other additional questions you
may have
that would be fine okay perfect
so the first question that the committee
had emailed us was concerning the
communication services tax
and if there were any further clarifying
um
answers to applying the tax to
video conferencing platforms
and i just wanted to say that we are
continuing to reach out
this is um a fairly new situation as you
know
our audit team is reaching out to look
at who is filing and who is not
filing and continue to get in get those
taxpayers into compliance
we don't have an exact revenue estimate
to apply to those taxpayers because we
do have to determine who is currently
paying and who is not paying
um however i think we have a zero
percent growth
and typically that cst has been a
declining
loss every month um or every year
so we think that keeping it at zero
including the voip and then including
these taxpayers to get them into
compliance
will equal to a zero percent growth
happy to answer any questions on cst
questions on cst
representative olney thank you mr
chairman
on can you tell us what
exactly they're supposed to be paying
tax on
a zoom-like object entity
yeah so it's a little sure it's a little
complicated
um so i'll try to keep it at a high
level
so it is a two-way communication the
video conferencing platform
and cst is taxable on that two-way video
conferencing platform
so whatever you're paying for the zoom
or
for the teams or forever
whichever video conferencing platform
you are using that
portion there should be a portion
taxable to new hampshire
um which portion gets a little bit
complicated
and i'm not going to try to to say that
because i don't want to
i don't want to say the wrong
information um our audit team is
definitely digging into that and making
sure
uh to find out which portion is taxable
but
because it is a two-way communication it
is classified as taxable for cst
melissa i as a customer
pay 15 dollars a month for the zoom
now that's a month it's not a function
of how long i use it
about a month so do i have to pay a tax
or
zoom have to pay a tax so typically cst
is
a consumer-based tax so the consumer is
paying it
a lot of people will see that on their
phone bill if they currently have a
phone bill
they'll see it at the bottom so
typically the taxpayer does pay it
however different platforms could tax it
differently meaning they could roll it
into the price so
what we don't know is that 15 that
you're speaking to
if if that is inclusive of their tax or
exclusive of the tax of the tax
because i don't get it from through my
phone
i get it through zoom itself okay
right so that's the part that um our
audit team is looking into it
all right the next one there were two of
us
where's the brownie reps of all me have
their hands up or up some major
oh okay i didn't see that representative
abrandi
oh thank you uh do you know if uh
we've captured some of the big boys like
zoom at this point
i know you can't talk about individual
companies but have we captured some of
the big boys or the
the ones who seem to have captured the
market the best in this
environment sure thank you for your
question
um we're still looking into that because
some
of the larger taxpayers do currently pay
with us
however what they're paying on i think
is what we're looking into to make sure
that that
video conferencing platform is included
so you could have one taxpayer who
offers multiple cst services that are
taxable but we want to make sure that
the video
online conferencing platforms are
taxable
so it's a little bit tricky to answer
okay you're working out then okay thank
you
representative thank you
on i paid for a year's license up front
rather than the 15 a month so on
i guess i got a one bill i don't
remember a bill
at all and um
so that's a different version of of how
they
allow this assume itself how they allow
you to
to pay for it um and i imagine
that that our cities and towns are or
we probably don't tax them or paid uh
are paying for
teams on a year at a time
they may not be but
on that just when you're trying to
figure out what's going on there are
yeah i'll be happy to share that with
i do not see any other raised hands
of the communication tax so
uh melissa utility property tax
sure so hopefully um you guys received
the utility property tax you
had requested a list of utilities that
paid this tax and that is available on
our website
so i i had forwarded along a link
to crochet for the most recent utility
property tax valuations and taxpayers
but if you go to our website we also
have historical views so i think that
answers question
two as for question three
for the utility property tax was our
dams included in this tax and if so are
the dams on the connecticut river are
portioned between new hampshire and
vermont when applying the tax
so we did a little research um dams are
taxed as utility property tax if they
are used for hydroelectric power
um and then for who pays the tax
it's actually based on what the um dam
reports so i'm just gonna i'm gonna
read the answer on this one if the case
if the case on dams on connecticut river
are utilized for hydro prop or hydro
power
the appraised value is allocated between
the two states the taxpayer reports the
cost of basis on their assets in both
states and we allocate final appraisal
value based on the cost
basis so it comes from um
it comes from the the utility the dam
actually says
how much of the appraised value is in
new hampshire and how much is in vermont
and then they pay that portion um
whichever is allocated to new hampshire
when i looked at the who pays that
utility property tax
the document you sent sentence about 35
pages
of people who pay that's tremendous but
just about every
community pays as well as dams and the
thank you mr chairman on i don't think
it's
at those utility pay payments i was
looking at the lebanon ones
and on there are companies that
have a piece of their their operation
inside lebanon
and it's based on how much property is
inside lebanon but
it's not lebanon that's paying it at
least not directly
and i looked at all the ones up and down
the connecticut river
and it looked like vermont was
paying more of it than i had expected
but
since the dam itself and
whatever is on our side is is uh
paid um is
on new hampshire but on
i guess the the one in
in lebanon and windsor i think it is
are is has got
part of its generation on the vermont
side
but i remember visiting the new
hampshire side of it and
there was more there i thought
yeah and where is this a a town
it's not the town it's the utility
building within that town like in my
town plaza we don't have any
water at all uh and
the building that utility owned within
our town is the one payment
any other questions of representative
on the utility property
yeah as like i mentioned uh last time
this is a comment um
there is a bill and uh that i'm a
co-sponsor of
uh the science and tech asked me to join
in with them
uh there's some discussion about
changing the assessment
uh parameters on this
uh going forward but i don't know where
this is going it really is not going to
impact
the total uh estimates that we're trying
to do
uh but i'll just mention that there's
some uh there's one assessor who's
claiming that the town that the the dams
aren't giving the proper information and
for them to do the proper assessing or
something like that
so we're we're uh we're looking at that
through the spill
it's gonna form a commission to look at
thank you um yeah this
i just want to be clear and make sure
that we're all clear on
[Music]
the taxation of utility properties
by using the utility prop statewide
the state's utility property tax and
then the statewide
education property tax and then the
local
tax on properties and uh maybe another
say
i'm sure you you've got that one down
and
if you could just explain it that would
help
um thank you representative ames i'm
actually gonna kick this to the
assistant commissioner utility property
is not my strong suit
um and i think she could probably better
explain it thanks good
i represented here let me turn my camera
on
so you can all see me um carol clear
commissioner at the new hampshire
department of revenue i think your
question
was you're looking for an explanation of
how
the utility property tax relates to
the statewide education property tax
and the local property tax is that right
yes so for purposes of
um state taxation of utilities
the department of revenue values
utilities
independently um and issues them
an assessment they pay that property tax
directly to the department and we
deposit that money into the education
trust fund
this is very different from how other
properties are
taxed um you know residential
or other commercial property gets valued
right at the municipal level and the
department although we oversee that
valuation process
just sort of accepts that valuation for
statewide property tax purposes
for utility property tax purposes the
municipalities
also value those utilities directly for
purposes of
assessing the local property tax um
and those values can be
somewhat different
you also have a good proportion of
municipalities that for whatever reason
likely due to the cost of hiring a
specialty assessor
just choose to utilize the department's
values for purposes of their local
property tax um is that what you were
looking for representative ames
well i um i think there's one other
point and that is that the
statewide education property tax
which um is uh
collected and billed by the localities
oh yes sure exactly right so as i said
the utility property tax gets collected
by the department directly
and we deposit right into the education
trust fund
whereas the swept applied
to all other properties it's collected
by the municipality on behalf of the
state
and they retain those dollars locally
that
swept um money never actually comes back
to the department for deposit into the
education trust fund
aka karen you said it's based upon
all other properties it's not based on
the same property
[Music]
no um it's the same all other properties
other than utility properties
okay i think the point is that that may
chime in that the
the statewide what we call swept
to simplify statewide education property
tax
[Music]
does not apply to the utilities
right they've been covered by the
state's utility property tax and to do
it
and so when the
localities send out that bill
they will not be sending it to the
utilities
and the other thing just to note this is
that there are actually two bills
one is mine that we'll be hearing
tomorrow
that would change the flow of
swept money it would still be built by
the municipalities but it would go to
into the state education trust fund
from the municipalities rather than
being kept locally as it is now
i'll watch that i tried doing that about
18 years ago
okay a brownie you stuff another hand up
or
i guess not i know i do i do i have my
hand up
i had to move quick here to get my thumb
on the uh commute
so as people have been around the
members that have been around you know i
had the bill on municipal property taxes
and uh what municipalities do when if
they have a power plant
in their jurisdiction like let's call
seabrook nuclear power plant
those municipalities usually negotiate a
value
of taxation with with like i think i
think seabrook plays two million dollars
a year
but that's a negotiated dollar amount so
when we were looking
and those things are ferc regulated
fairly regulated uh utilities
and there's three pieces to utilities
there's the generation
there's the big transmission lines
transmission lines that go across the
state
they're also fork regulated and then the
then there's the distribution which are
the smaller lines the ones in front of
your house
that are more locally regulated so when
we did our work we
we didn't look at generation we didn't
look at
at the large-scale transmission lines
because they
that wasn't broken we really worked on
the local transmission
to come up with a formula for the
municipalities to
to tax uh come up with a property tax
value of those
so i guess when we're talking about
generation
generation not every town has generation
uh
a few of them do of some kind i was i
was also very surprised at how many dams
we have that uh
it was very surprising how many dams we
had that generate uh
power uh throughout the state um
but and then the other variable i'm just
thinking of
well i don't want to go let me stop
there so what i'm getting at there's two
pieces
there's municipal taxing and then the
state
one last thought is that the state does
evaluate
all property uh as well as utility
uh property and
and and the uh including the
distribution stuff
and about 20 of the towns
just accept that number they accept
whatever the state's number is and don't
use their own assessors to do it
as well for the local distribution part
so
but anyway i think i was i don't know if
i clarified anything but
uh it's not as yes i agree with dick
games that
represent ames that there are different
pieces to this
and just a piece of information
is that when the towns evaluate
utility property that the state doesn't
such as polls some towns would
say put a value of a hundred dollars on
a poll
another town would put a value of two
thousand dollars in that fall
and that created quite a controversy
in providing and also created some
legislation that
went through that just a few years all
right can i interject one other thing
just to complicate it
there's there's telephone poles and
there's electric poles
they're different there there they're
assessed differently telephone because
utilities are regulated uh but but
telecommunication isn't a regulated
industry
so we actually as a legislature as a
ways and means came up with
first year we came up with how to assess
telephone and telecommunication
polls and then the next year or two we
came up with a way of
of uh of evaluating
utility properties which includes gas
electric
and water and we don't have we don't
have many public water we do
we don't we have very little gas
distribution but sometimes do have gas
distribution
so um i'll leave it at that thank you it
hasn't been simple
any further questions or comments on the
utility
property tax if not melissa would you go
to the interest and dividend tax
and that's where we had asked for a
breakdown yeah
so i think um i'm hoping you had
received a couple of weeks ago we gave
the breakdown
of the district the different types of
um
components the ind makes up we did a tax
year 18 in taxer 19 as well as in your
presentation
okay perfect but what i think the other
question was that has come up a couple
of times is the difference between the
dividends and distributions for the ind
tax
um so looking at this
and this is strictly before i speak it's
strictly for new hampshire ind purposes
it's a little bit different than how you
typically think of distributions and
dividends
in the corporate world or for federal
purposes so for
ind purposes based on statute and rules
a distribution distributions are any
transfer of property
from organizations to owners purely as a
result of ownership in a company
so those are the distributions and then
when you get to dividends
dividends are a subset of distributions
so a dividend for ind purposes
are a type of distribution that are
either non-liquidating distributions
or are based on current year profit or
accumulated profit
so if your distribution doesn't fall
into those two categories
it's a distribution but if it falls into
either a non-liquidated distribution or
a current year profit or accumulated
profit
then it's considered a dividend so a
little bit different there so i just
wanted to
clarify that because i know there's been
a lot of questions in the last few
meetings about the difference between
the a distribution and a dividend
for the ind tax purposes and
the shifting of those looking at a
10-year
trend and we can get you that chart as
well they haven't shifted all that much
over the last five
years basically interest makes up 13
dividends 40 distributions 39
and then exempt federal interest is
about 8 percent
happy to answer any questions
representatives
thank you mr chairman could you possibly
put that
on definition in writing
and send absolutely it's it's straight
from our rules so i can send that over
great and then the second uh question is
within the bet
there is a piece which is uh
on distributions it's not called that i
think but distributions to
owners and partnerships and is it
defined the same way or
business enterprise tax i think it's
dividends paid or accrued
um is the component that it's paid on i
can
my assumption is and i'll look it up i
don't think it's the same as ind
is very specific as to how they um
define a dividend um but i will
definitely look it up but my assumption
is no i think it's going to be a
straight
um a straight corporate dividend
is what's going to be under that
dividends um paid or accrued for
for bet but i can absolutely send you
the answer for that
yeah it'd be good to have the
definitions for both of those
keep that in mind thank you thank you
susan
uh representative randy make sure we
understand um
so dividends and distributions one are
they taxed the same
and when are they not taxed the same or
sure so they're both taxed at five
percent um they just fall into different
categories on the form
is essentially how it comes down to so
they're still being no matter what
they're being
taxed to five percent yeah thank you
okay thank you um
this is a tech this is a question about
your your
on your in your annual report the
inverted pyramid
presentation that you do
which is a very helpful source of
information for all of us
but one piece of it that blurs over
distinctions that i'd like to be able to
see
is that your category right in the
middle of the chart
one thousand dollar of tax reported
to ten thousand dollars of tax reported
lumps together um
people who at the one thousand dollar
level have oh let's say
um maybe four hundred thousand dollars
of uh of uh assets that are producing
you know you can take you can you can
assume whatever
uh rate you you want but but it's that
kind of level of assets that
lead to um a one thousand dollar
tax whereas uh for the at the other end
of
of this group of taxpayers
receiving ten thousand reporting ten
thousand dollars of tax
you're talking about millions probably
unless they had a very lucky year of um
holdings that produce the
revenue the income that then is taxed at
five percent
so um my question is whether you have
data that would
sure um we definitely have the data that
makes up those categories and which
components are making up those
categories
so it sounds like it might be helpful to
take that subset of taxpayers and then
maybe make another graph of showing what
their components are
or what assets they have and that
they're paying taxes on
that equal that one thousand to ten
thousand that would be really helpful to
have
from my perspective sure we can get that
for you
for the much on the interest and
sand none then the tobacco tax
sure so the the question you had on tv
representative elmi did you have i'm
sorry um we don't have an answer yet
dewey about the the um question
about the division of how many
people at different levels of the
interest and dividends tax
um how much money on
would be lost if we increase the
exemption for the interest and dividends
tax by
increments sure um devin did a great job
working on that
last week so i think it's about ready to
be sent over so you should have that
within the next day
great thank you you're welcome thank you
susan
um so far sorry i have a plow going by i
don't know if that's loud
um for tobacco attacks for e-cigarettes
first off we do have a chart within our
monthly report so i'm hoping that
the committee members are receiving that
chart as well as the new committee
members we send out daily charts of
revenues after the
15th of the month as well as monthly
charts at the end of the month
that have about i think eight charts in
it that further break down our revenues
and within one of those charts is a bond
receivable balance
tobacco chart and at the bottom of that
tobacco chart is an e-cigarette chart
that shows us the monthly amount of
revenue that has been received since
implementation of this tax
so this tax was implemented
um in january and they pay on the
following month for this tax in the
other tobacco product or otp return
so for fiscal year 21 this tax brought
in 1.2 million dollars from february to
june
and so far this year from july through
january
it's brought in 2.5 million and it's
about
300 to 400 000 a month and it seems to
vary with a high in october
of 458 000
um in a low in august of 304 000.
but right now like i said it's hovering
around three to four
questions
could i ask a question about that sorry
it's harder to raise my hand that it's
just unmute
uh can
could we see the variation between the
months
to see if there's a relationship they're
collecting
as they sell aren't they so so
if it's a variation according to the
coved spurts or something like that
sure so in our monthly tobacco chart it
does break it out by month
oh great and if you need that again just
let me know and we can forward just that
report
saying uh he has his hand up reps and
major
representative romney as well as
represent tucker
thank you um melissa um anyway you have
a
you may not have this kind of detail but
a split between the open systems and the
closed systems
the closed systems or the jewels of the
world um
in the open system so you refill the
canister whatever that
device any way of telling because the
different tax rates for the two
so i'm thinking maybe there's a way of
telling
how much revenue is due to each one
first so we don't currently have a
report that does that however we do have
that data and that's how we compile the
e-cigarette reports so we could pull
that together
and we can do it from the from the
beginning so we can do um february
february till now february of last year
till now and have it broken out by
open system and closed systems per month
thank you
representative tucker yes i wanted to
talk about a
different matter in my district uh
coast five we had a major fire
at the town hall of jefferson and
the people of jefferson and particularly
the people who work at town hall
are so grateful to dra for reaching out
almost immediately to explain how they
can work
with the town of jefferson to
[Music]
organize the materials that were lost in
the fire that
are held at dra to be helpful for the
town meeting
to be helpful for the town report and
offered
every possible assistance and i just
want to take this opportunity it's a
part of dra we don't think about
the reaching out to towns and cities to
be helpful
and i just want to say thank you very
very much on behalf
of jefferson residents
great thank you i'll be sure to pass
that on to our municipal and property
division
they do a great job so i'll let them
know that you said that i think they'll
thank you sorry on i
i also i read recently
i think it was in my local paper but
maybe not it was an
article about uh the e-cigarettes
and how on young people were switching
to a product that is disposable
it is like the closed
system but it is disposable and the
article made it
sound like it was considered
untaxable because it was different from
the closed
system do you know anything about this
i am not familiar with that and i have
not seen that article but if you'd like
to forward that along
we can absolutely take a look at it i'm
we thank the dra for coming in this
morning
and go to the
next court
which is the new hampshire lodging and
wrestling association
mike summers who is president and ceo is
he is represented major we'll just bring
him into the meeting
he's in the meeting and mr summers
you're ready to go you should have a
share screen if you want to do that
well good morning mr chairman members of
the committee
for the record my name is mike summers
i'm the president ceo of the new
hampshire lodging and restaurant
association
i was approached and asked to come in
and talk a little bit about
uh kind of the state of the hospitality
industry uh challenges we've faced
um and then talk a little bit about what
we see for
potentially a year or so ahead of us so
um
i'll just jump right into it but um i
believe you received this deck in
advance i had sent it to chris
i think late sunday um
so obviously i think the the common
knowledge here is that um the industry
has been extremely impacted by
the pandemic uh we had the closures in
march of 2020
and it was a very strong road back from
there um
the one thing i will say is that you
know across the industry
not all business models were impacted
equally i think it's fair to say that uh
business models that were based on more
of a takeout and delivery model
think of your average uh mcdonald's
pizza shop sub shop etc
uh certainly fared much better uh than
casual
and fine dining were the biggest uh
impacts for we're seeing and then
switching gears to lodging you know it's
fair to say that the lodging and events
side of our industry
was dramatically impacted early on um
you know again everyone with the
uh safer at home orders uh alike not
only here but across the country
essentially ground to a whole for a good
three or four months there
um we did see a little bit of a rebound
in the summer of last year
um we did see a fair amount of leisure
travel i think the one thing
that's worth noting is that corporate
travel uh almost disappeared overnight
so
after the first uh sheltered home orders
were issued
corporate travel has not come back um
certainly there's some essential travel
but this certainly not
certainly not anywhere close to what it
has been you know 2019 and earlier and
frankly we don't see that really
recovering
uh uh fully until sometime in 2024.
um just a snapshot you know we estimate
that somewhere around 723 million or
uh in gross sales has been lost to the
industries about 23
and and also keep in mind that uh for
the
for the you know take out delivery
restaurants many of those folks were
certainly
um doing the business they were doing in
um casual and and fine dining were down
as much as
you know 40 and 50 so again not all
business models were equal
again we still continue to see roughly 7
000 people in our industry
percent of our workforce that are uh
unemployed
we continue to see them listed on the
continuing claims
um what that number doesn't really share
with you is the number of folks who are
underemployed and we still continue to
hear stories from members about
businesses that are uh you know uh
limited hours
or shortened hours or a variety of other
uh accommodations and adjustments that
they've made
um and then obviously loans and cares
act funds have been
uh critical in helping our industry
survive to this point
um and i'm sure you're all aware as well
as i am that uh you know congress
continues to wrestle with
another uh aid package so we will uh
wait
uh to see what that looks like um and
then the last consideration
uh for you just overall is that you know
we've seen a dramatic increase in costs
of running
uh both restaurants and hotels obviously
you know the providing ppe
uh sanitation sanitizing products and
protocols
uh energy costs food costs etc
everything has gone up
uh across the board so it is not only
making less money but it's costing us
more to make that money so it has
certainly
been a challenging uh 12-month period
here
um specifically to restaurants um
again we talked about the the various
business models we talked about quick
service restaurants have done
quite well uh considering um the casual
fine dining sector
um and then on the workforce
uh one thing that i will share with you
is that uh the summer months of last
year
were critically important to the
industry the expanded outdoor dining
that uh many restaurants took advantage
of
um i can't i can't overstate how
important that was to many of them
uh to really just uh shore up the
finances and really get through uh to
where we are today
um and and we obviously extend our
thanks to all the municipalities who
went beyond
help our restaurants really take
advantage of that opportunity
um you know whether it was closing up
parking spaces with jersey berries and
all the
myriad things that all the
municipalities did to chip in and help
uh was it was a game changer for for
many in the industry
on the logic side of things um you know
again
they were closed at 50 percent or closed
for a period of time then they opened at
i think we got back to 100 in june of
last summer um but again we can see that
uh
consumer demand demand is down overall
um
and just a couple of numbers that i can
share with you our room oxygen
rates in 2020 we're down 33 versus 2019
and the room revenue was down 41 so
not only were fewer people traveling
they'll pay less per room so that
certainly impacted not only
revenues for the industry but it impacts
up impacts obviously
meals and rentals tax um again
as i stated earlier uh a big a big part
of the
the saw were tied directly to
um corporate travel that really has just
evaporated
um and we talked about the workforce
the event side of the history uh
obviously they were closed uh i think
longer than anyone else um and those
severe restrictions continue to be in
place event facilities right now which
many hotels have event facilities in
them but this also includes
independent carrying companies uh
outside catering companies etc
um they're still operating at 50
capacity tables of six
so that has not changed to date um and
due to those restrictions there's a
great deal of uncertainty around events
for this coming summer
uh one thing i will tell you is uh there
are a lot of folks
um who potentially postponed weddings or
whatever it might be from
last year and pushed them into this year
that are kind of on the bottle right now
there are certainly
uh many of them hoping to to prevents
this year
and frankly if you know some of these
restrictions are lifted there is a
chance that we could have a very good
summer for the event side of the
industry but
um you know as things stand right now
there's a little bit of uncertainty so
we're certainly hopeful that uh we start
to get some advanced notice of what
uh easing of restrictions might look
like and again i think
for all the industries we've spoken to
it's all about the vaccine the faster
the vaccine can get out there
the more likely we will start to see
consumer confidence rebound
and ultimately start to take advantage
of
our obviously facilities
the the toughest stretch in this entire
year really for our industry
is right now um you know january
february march uh it's the winter time
it's a
historically slow part of the year we
have not had a huge amount of
so we've certainly seen um west
travelers on the roads
um and i think that's uh played out in
the um
uh toll reports uh that we watch as as
i'm sure you do
i think we're down 20 or so on most of
the highway toll
reports um we do anticipate that
by second quarter of this year um you
know
april may june we will see uh some
recovery
um that's likely going to be in the form
of leisure travelers
actually a little bit of corporate
travel but again i
think that's going to be modest at best
um
but we are hopeful that by q3 of this
year so
uh july august september we're hoping
that there will be some semblance of
normal
we hope that the restaurant hotel and
event industries will have a pretty good
finish to to the summer season and uh
and a decent fall
so as i mentioned i think the biggest
uh factor in all of this and what the
path ahead looks like is really going to
be consumer confidence
which is really going to be driven by
the level of vaccine distribution
uh and the light so um one thing i will
say is we do
anticipate some pent up demand from
leisure travelers dining out
entertainment
we expected that will start potentially
as soon as uh
april may and hopefully go through the
rest of the year
um but again i think depending on the
individual is going to depend on their
likelihood that they're going to take
advantage of what's available to them
um again i think 2021 this year will be
uh much better than last year
uh but certainly uh far behind where we
were in 2018 2019
and obviously operating costs will
continue to be a challenge
so that's kind of the down and dirty of
what i'd like to share with you today
i think what um might make more sense is
uh
to try to um try to answer any questions
you may have
thank you mike representative southwood
as a question thank you for taking my
question
i would like to start with a compliment
i'm from the dover area
and the restaurants really have been
great as far as being creative with
delivery outdoor dining all kinds of
things
i do think this is a created a loyalty
so i do think when things open up
the customers really know where you know
people have been serving them well so
i do want to compliment the group on
that
for my question in the seacoast the bars
and pubs are especially popular very
crowded
but i also know with the virus probably
the most risky areas
and they'll probably be the last to open
up fully
well first thank you for your kind words
um the industry certainly has been very
creative
uh in trying to work through this issue
regarding your question to bars um i
think bars i would i would kind of
categorize with the event side of things
because these are essentially or
historically
spaces where people would kind of crowd
together um
in you know consolidated numbers uh so
we
we are hopeful again that there's a lot
of assumptions in this statement
obviously that
uh but if if we do see vaccine
distribution continue
to uh pick up which we are seeing now
starting to take place
if what we are hearing from national and
state officials that
you know by the time we get into april a
fair number of folks will have been
vaccinated especially the high-risk
folks
um you know we would start we would
think we would start to see that some of
those restrictions will begin to ease
and then really it's about consumer
confidence and and that's the really
fickle part of all of this we we can
certainly
uh prognosticate about what uh what we
think will happen
based on vaccine distribution based on a
variety of things but
it's really going to boil down to when
are consumers ready to come out
uh and dine out and and that's that's
the
million-dollar question i guess a
follow-up
um yeah actually i guess it's kind of a
follow off but
do you have a sense of the um places
that will not reopen
do you kind of have that on your radar
so that's a very difficult question to
answer
as i'm sure you can imagine you know
historically the restaurant industry has
a fair and a fair amount of turnover in
a good year
so we will certainly see a number of
restaurants will come in number of
restaurants will go out
um we have been trying to keep a track
or an idea of how many businesses we
think
have gone out dude directly related to
the pandemic versus just you know
operational challenges whatever it might
be and frankly
i don't know that we're ever going to
get to that number uh in a clean fashion
so
you know we saw an awful lot of
restaurant owners in the early part of
the pandemic who just retired
you know they were within three or four
years of their target retirement anyway
and they realized that they could spend
an awful lot of time effort resources
trying to survive and come back from
this pandemic and they made the decision
that they're just going to retire so we
have seen
what's not clear to me is of the group
that we saw that did the hibernations
it's not clear to me how many of those
are going to come back and there were a
fair number of them in the seacoast
and so you know there's a couple of
challenges there first of all
when you close the restaurant for three
months it's essentially the same as
reopening your business from scratch
you've got to have the capital and the
wherewithal to you know purchase
inventory
hiring trained staff you're essentially
starting from from zero
um and what also is concerning to to me
and the rest of the industry is
if you take a look at uh our workforce
if you've essentially
sideline them for three or four months
will they become back to your business
um and we're not sure about that there
is obviously
a number of other industries that have
been functioning quite well
manufacturing healthcare and others
they're
desperate for help right now so how many
of uh how what percentage of our
workforce will make the decision to
switch careers
again there are a lot of questions there
and i don't know that i have any uh
serious and solid answers for you
unfortunately thank you that was helpful
okay before we go to represent all me i
do have a question for you mike
do you know of many restaurants that
started the restaurant in say
october and november 2019 because of
starting in 2019 we're not
eligible for ppe loans and therefore
they haven't been able to survive were
there many
of these type of an eligible ppp
loans so couple of points
uh to make so uh we we are aware of
restaurants and even some hotels who
essentially had open dates there was a
hotel right here in concord their open
date was supposed to be april of 2020.
i don't believe they open until
something like october of 2020 so
uh we've certainly seen a lot of
businesses that opened or were ready to
open
you know october november uh 2019
even through the you know summer of last
year that were essentially forced to
open simply because they had
uh a lot of capital and and lease
obligations that they had to to meet so
so we're certainly seeing a lot of
businesses in that space and they've
been a lot of businesses to
to appoint mr chairman that we're not
eligible for ppp
loans uh thankfully there were some
other instruments that they could
access so for example the economic
injury and disaster loans the idle loans
those were available and many of them
were able to get it to get those
um unfortunately those businesses that
did not qualify for ppp loans
many of them did also also did not
qualify for cares act funds so therefore
they were not able to get main street
relief the cell funds or whatever it
might be so
there have been a lot of businesses that
have kind of fallen through the cracks
um you know i don't have a hard number
for you but that certainly has been
something that we've been watching
we have been in touch with our
congressional delegation we've asked
them
as part of the next round of aid that is
being talked about right now that
there be some carve out that would be
specifically helpful to those newer
businesses who started
late 2019 early 2020 that uh
have received no support thus far or
very little support
that there'd be some set aside or some
eligibility that would allow them to
access some additional funds
again i'm of the opinion that the
businesses that can make it to
you know memorial day weekend or a
little later i think that if they can
make it to there they've made it across
the finish line i think they got a
chance to make it uh
and survive um but you know this is a
really critical time for a lot of
businesses they've
they've spent the aid that they've
gotten they've many of them have burned
through a lot of their personal equity
in these businesses
there's not a lot left in the till so
they're going to need a little bit to
get them over the finish line and
whatever bit that they get if we can get
them to memorial day i think they've got
a legitimate shot of making it through
this mess so
thank you mr chairman on
like when we when when businesses
open up uh reps restaurants are lodging
do they automatically join your
association can you can you
track all of them or on is it just the
ones that decide to
that is a good thing to join uh thank
you for the question representative
i wish that was the case that is
unfortunately not the case um
like a lot of chambers of commerce etc
it is a uh
an option um we certainly encourage
folks to join us uh we give them timely
information variety of other products
and services but
there is no requirement that they join
the organization so unfortunately i
don't have
really hard numbers that i can share
with you thank you and as
to follow up on do you have an idea of
the normal churn
i've been thinking that that on after
when things start to be
safe a lot more people might be coming
out and trying their hand at
restauranting and i know a number of
people that
have set up on restaurants now
because but are there they're they're
only working with themselves
not with any any workers yet because
there isn't much demand yet
um do you have an idea of the normal
churn how many
leave and how many start
yeah it fluctuates by years i'm sure you
can imagine but we anticipated somewhere
around 10 or 15 percent
um and and you know in good years like
2019 it may be as low as three four five
percent
and other years more challenging years
could be a little higher
um but but ultimately that's a range
that we see
um you know into your question or your
following question about
uh how many restaurants uh hotels do we
anticipate are going to open
i think a lot of uh plans are on hold
right now i think that
um there will likely be some opportunity
where some businesses
unfortunately closed as a result of the
pandemic so there will be some that
have the wherewithal that may think this
is a great opportunity but
i do suspect that it's going to be later
this year before
much later this year before i think a
lot of folks are going to jump in
we're certainly seeing some smaller uh
uh
folks start up right now specifically
around a lot of grab and go type stuff
whether it be
you know coffee shops and things like
that but to see a full-blown you know
sit-down restaurant
restaurant or hotel i suspect it's going
to be linked this year before they even
consider something like that
representative romney thank you summers
good to see you again um so my
question's about corporate travel
and whether there's going to be a new
normal um
i think eventually conferences and
conventions will come back that
involve businesses because of the
socialization part of it people like
going and meeting their peers
working other companies and all that but
that may take a little bit of time
but when it comes to normal business
travel
and after a year of zooms
do you anticipate that there will be
less corporate travel
as the new norm and that zooming will
continue
now that impacts everything then that
impacts car rentals meals and hotels
if i'm going from here to new york city
uh to
a conference with a client a meeting
with a client that
well you know maybe we could just do
this by zoom
so have you thought about that much in
terms of uh
i'm just just trying to figure out a
little bit as to whether you think
there may be a new norm in travel
business travel
it's a great question representative
obama thank you question um
my sense of it is that we're gonna have
a tale here i i think what's gonna
happen is we will likely continue to be
a zoom culture for a lot of business
meetings
uh for the next six to 12 months but i
really think that there's something to
be said for the personal touch right so
when you talk about a sales call
uh you know investment meeting whatever
it might be
we do anticipate that we'll come back uh
we just
anticipate it's gonna come back in a big
way until probably 2022
maybe 2023 um and i think it's going to
vary by industry it's going to vary by
corporate culture it's going to vary by
a lot of factors
but i think that folks do like to get
together um you know
it's the wine and dying scenario that
we've all heard of so
um we think it will come back but we
just do think it will be delayed
um and we certainly think it's going to
impact obviously
industry revenues and state revenues at
least for the next six to 12 months at
least
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
summers for coming in to talk to us
today i just have a comment
um you know for 25 years i worked as one
of those business travelers i left every
sunday and came back home every thursday
and i was
in planes and trains and automobiles and
hotels and taxis and
everything that you can think of by
modes of transportation and places to
say
restaurants eating out every night um i
spoke this past week
with the president of the corporation
that i retired from
and i asked him particularly about
this and that company has now created a
new business model
uh that there's a certain portion of
their consultants
that will no longer be traveling they
will only be doing
a business by in the same fashion that
we're speaking right now
um and uh they said that that
while they will have some people that
are going out to do that personal touch
just as you were talking about just now
that they are create they have created
and they have a business model that is
working very well
and this is a 100 million dollar company
that um
that had you know 70 employees that flew
all over the place every week
now the way the health crisis has
affected
uh all of us in the united states we are
seeing business models that are being
formed
that are sort of cutting out this
completely
and i know that this is going to have a
definite impact
so i just want to make that statement
just to say that we are talking to other
people in the industries
uh and and i agree with you that it's
going to be a while before it's going to
come back
and it's probably not going to come back
also thank you for the comment and and i
i do agree that there are going to be a
lot of
large companies that are going to be
very hesitant to travel but
i i think the reason we always had
corporate travel was that the
the personal touch was ultimately the
more successful right
so uh you whine and die in a client you
uh you know you talked through it you
built a personal relationship with them
and and frankly i think that the folks
that continue to adopt that will likely
be
the more successful and so you are right
going to be a long tail there will
likely be
uh varying versions of the business
model you describe and i absolutely
believe that
but i think that ultimately again
there's a lot to be
a personal touch and frankly i think
that that will ultimately win the day
that's why we ended up with the
corporate culture that we've had because
it has been successful for
for very very long period of time
thank you any any further questions
chris um at this point you have nobody
scheduled until 11 o'clock
at that point you'll have the new
hampshire housing finance authority
coming in
so i don't know if you want to address
any of the outstanding taxes you have or
revisit any of the taxes that
revenues excuse me that you discussed
last week why don't you
know the communication services because
you were waiting for a response from the
department today
uh you provided an updated
yeah and i can share that with the
yes uh if there's any
if there's no questions at this point
if there isn't then go ahead press um
well you have two questions reps of
major uh season represent major you have
reps of a bromine
represent army oh representative put his
hand down
thank you i wanted to bring up that
newspaper article that i shared with
everybody
last week and it would be that probably
dra is left
but on it seems to give
a very good on reasons
reasons for why we're seeing the revenue
increases
that that we have been seeing throughout
the pandemic and that the whole country
has or
apparently some states not but have been
seeing
on and i think that it's going to be
worth discussing at some point
thanks thank you any
any other questions or comments before
we go to the website
okay chris so on
friday i believe i sent out the revised
worksheet
um where i included the governor's
estimates
these estimates don't um reflect any
changes
that are being made as you know the tax
changes or any other
suggested revenue impacts these are just
the numbers pulled from
um the information i sent you which was
the exhibit b
from the budget which is the
unrestricted revenues as well as the
executive summary it could
respect both current law and
and is this right so it's not just
current law that you're looking at and
and i do have a document from the
governor's office
um that i haven't had a chance to fully
go through
but um it's what matt will present to
you on
thursday it'll break out um
you'll have a base estimate and it'll
break out what the changes the impact of
those revenue changes might be for
for instance the business tax the bet um
threshold changing and
the bet um decreasing the rate to 5.55
um so just but i felt the committee
might want to see
at least some information as you're
talking about this
and i think it's um it's probably good
you know as you go across you can see
your numbers aren't
you know the agency high lows are not
really out of whack compared to what the
governor estimates show you
or even what you agreed to last week
doesn't mean that you may not want to
revisit some of these but it's
just wanted to get that to the committee
that if there was any um
questions as to how the governor was
lining up with his estimates compared to
what
the agencies were sharing with you as
well as what you came to some
conclusions on last week
when we meet with the governor's budget
director on thursday
he knows we want to be able to have him
tell us what part of
his estimate his current law and what
and and what is it all right and
estimates
and he's provided that to me represent
major i just had
it's not um i didn't want to send out
another document because it doesn't
compare to this document in front of you
um because in this document
you have some things that i've adjusted
for that aren't adjusted in some of the
base numbers that
i got from the mat the other day so i
just want to go through and make sure i
don't
i clean it up so that it looks similar
to what you've been looking at and then
explain where there's changes
for instance the anomalies the 30.8
million dollars in anomalies
information that i got from the
governor's budget director
subtracts that at the end of their
estimate so it's not done by each tax
type
where in your in this case what i
provided you for the agency
high and low it is accounted for already
so instead of at the end of the process
i've done it on the front side of it
so but by by the end of tomorrow you'll
get a document so that you can
see what the governor's um estimates are
in terms of current law and as well as
what they are it relates to any changes
that they're going to put in
um house bill 2 or the trailer bill
and the trailer bill is not ready it
won't be ready for a short bit
um the governor's office did provide
language
um as required for the chapter law last
budget session
um but similar to any lsr it's now with
the sponsor and has to go through ols
and
um language has to be cleaned up to kind
of fit what ols does for
drafting but hopefully we'll have that
you know within a short period of time
does the
trailer bill is that up-to-date
on those things that affect revenues
um yes it will it has the language you
know or or what the
um governor intends to do with his
budget as he would
need to make it work um what
it's a draft though it's not done in the
ols format as you would see a
build being introduced so that ols needs
to go through that process of looking at
what changes are being recommended
and checking statutes current statutes
seeing what needs to change
making sure that all the referencing and
cross-referencing is correct and
so that's that's what takes some time so
when we meet with the governor on
thursday
yeah uh i think i'm unmuted um
so uh the the the question is
the question you've basically that
you've been putting out there
is house bill 2 and changes uh
from current law that are somehow
embedded in
the governor's estimates and you just
brought up another wrinkle which is the
treatment of the anomalies
so i just i just wanted to say i almost
took my hand down but
it really it's absolutely essential that
we
get that information i'm glad that you
have a document that will allow
i guess you to share what your sense of
how the governor's non-current law
pieces
play into his estimates but we really
can't
look at at his numbers say for
all meals and rooms or business taxes or
ind
and understand it at all without having
that information correct
that's one of the main reasons we're
meeting with the governor's budget
director
the regular revenue estimates getting
what all the additions to the revenues
are
so so if i might i mean
uh the governor's budget director will
will discuss with you um
you know the changes and the estimates
that they have related to the the
changes that they want in the
make related to the tax laws um and
the document he provided me does break
that out um
the anomalies are there what i'm trying
to do is be consistent in the approach
that you see the numbers so you don't
see two different numbers and wonder if
there's an error or a mistake
i'm also checking the numbers as they
you know i compare them to what
matt has in his document he provided me
last night as compared to what the
governor issued on last thursday
making sure that there was no what i
would call fat finger you know of
information being a number and being
omitted or
or transposed by accident so just it's
cleaning it up making sure that the
in terms of you know if the committee
members that were here last session
if you remember the document that um
i had created was an excel document that
had basically the base estimate numbers
at the top half of the page and at the
bottom half of the page were where
um there were changes to current law yes
how the
budget director set it up for me based
on my request to him and
and that's what i'll end up providing to
the committee so it should be
in that sense you just may not see
language in house bill 2 but you have
the
elements of what's changing based on the
summary document that you should have
all received in the mail or will receive
in the mail
um you know it basically describes some
of the changes that
the governor is recommending and matt
will be able to address committee's
well this is a good starting point uh
for uh thursday
uh you have representative all on me and
representative bromi that have questions
represent major
representative followed by
representative romney
thank you mr chairman chris
when when you get hb2
on you're going to be going through it
i'm sure to see
what sections are relative to
our revenues and that
would include anything that turns into a
dedicated fund or comes out of a
dedicated fund
um and
on can you possibly
maybe hb2 or something like that provide
us
an index to the page numbers that those
are on because
it is sometimes even the analysis
doesn't use the same words
so that you can't search on the computer
easily for the place that is in the
analysis
so the answer is yes representative only
and typically our office does put
together an index to house bill 2.
usually it's just on the in the budget
documents on on our website
but what i can do when we do that is i
can notate for the committee those um
sections that you may have an interest
in looking at and and i'll email that to
the
entire committee when it's available so
i would just say you know i would do
something like you know sections
two through four address the change in
business enterprise tax
sections blah and it'll be i'll
highlight the index for you
so you can find it easily very good
representative
yeah thank you um you know even though
we don't have hb2 in front of us on
thursday let's say
i'm i'm assuming that the governor's uh
budget fellow knows that
you know what the tax cuts are and he
will describe them to us
um i mean uh you know yeah i agree with
representative army that it'd be nice to
have it referenced
so we can double check that it's correct
eventually
uh but i think what he looking here on
thursday is pretty much
what it's going to be unless he forgets
to put something in that that is an hb2
uh so is that is that correct that would
be correct representative abrami i mean
matt will be able to talk to you about
you know what their plans are with the
say you know the business enterprise tax
and when they
you know intend for that to have an
impact on your revenues and
you know um you know the interest in
dividends and what they're proposing for
that he'll be able to talk you through
that
um you just don't have a document
sitting in front of you that
states that as well that will come after
the fact and again it's just a timing
issue
it's the governor's office provided
everything like they were
expected to by yesterday afternoon
now it's just a matter of getting it um
through the lsr
type of process getting it drafted into
a bill
and and that process there may be some
things that are in the
you know the uh document that was
provided that may end up in other places
you know that for instance there might
be a reference to a capital project
maybe it needs to go to house bill 25
and not stay in the trailer bill you
know so those are the types of things
that we're in the process of trying to
look at we again we've just gotten it so
um our office hasn't really had a chance
to really go through it yet
have a follow-up norm we'll follow up
so it'd be helpful in the documents that
he shared with us on thursday
would have a little guide as to what the
tax was and the
applicability dates of some of these tax
you know it's effective uh tax periods
ending or
uh or after a certain date or you know
something like that
that we haven't hard copy yep i'll i'll
make that request to matt
any further questions or comments
relative to the worksheet
that we're going to be discussing on
thursday
if not then
at 11 o'clock just one other thing
representative just to update the
committee i still don't have anybody
from health and human services
um i reached out i've reached out almost
every single day last week
and um at this point i still don't have
a name to come before the committee
they might give me something today or
tomorrow and if they do i'll schedule
them for
thursday as well um
but at this point we have nobody coming
in to talk about
covid um uh vaccinations
variants you know the changes were seen
um you know with the numbers you know
most recently compared to what was
happening so but again i just want to
let the committee know
i've continued to work on that i just
don't have a response from the
department
let's talk off offline on that chris
okay 11 o'clock mr chairman
can i have a question in the chair are
doesn't look like we were going to be
meeting this afternoon because
we don't have somebody from hhs but
we'll finish up this morning and then
this afternoon
um there will be an opportunity for the
republicans to have a caucasian
at 2 30. i sent that link out to all the
republicans on the committee if you
haven't received that link
give me a call so that
i have all the verbs in except for the
blurb for house bill
528 so the glare for
house bill 528 you can get that to me
today
i certainly appreciate it
is there any questions before we take a
break until
11 o'clock where we'll be hearing from
the new hampshire finance authority
i don't see any questions so we'll take
a break until
this
hello chris yes runs the major
uh uh is dean and ben here
they are they're ready to speak um
they're on the call right now and
uh dean and ben if you need to share
your screen you have the ability to do
that as well
but i did forward the document that you
provided to the committee
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee this is dean kristen uh ben
frost
is joining me as well i know he spoke
with you earlier in the year
i appreciate the opportunity to chat
with you today
um i think we did provide as
chris requested some data some of which
is basically
um updates of information that you saw
earlier in the year some of which is
design
we hope to address some of the specific
questions that we were asked to try to
address
to the extent that we're able to um to
identify information to do that
if i may what i might ask is if
ben can share his screen we will go
through
these charts quickly and then obviously
either he or i will
be happy to try to answer your questions
so um if that's all right
yes it will be thank you sir
so um we'll start just quickly here i
know that the focus of the
the conversation we want to have today i
need to
that i can see what i'm apologize about
um so um
the um the focus of the conversation
today is really the
the for sale side of the market but i
did want to just start by setting a
little context reminding
everyone of the dynamics of our rental
market as well because
there are interconnectivities here and
what goes on in the rental market does
impact
the for sale or purchase market as well
so
um just quickly i know ben shared some
of this information with the committee
earlier in the year but
we track rental costs on an annual basis
through a very comprehensive survey
on a statewide basis as well as
regionally and you will note that
the trend that we have identified really
over more than a decade continues
uh which is that the cost of rental
units in the state continues to
increase uh they have increased um
pretty steadily over that decade or so
and in the last five years
the increase has been about 22 percent
for a two-bedroom unit which is really
the
sort of marker um unit that we use
because that's the
most of the rental units in the state
are two bedrooms
the importance of this is that that rate
of increase is probably about
twice the rate of increase in renter
incomes and therefore
it has created affordability challenges
for people and that's relevant for the
purchase side of the market because it
really undermines the ability of people
who might be trying to save
to purchase home because it basically
increases demands on them and
their ability to pay for
and undermines their ability to pay for
their housing generally
next sideband if you can please the
other
factor here that is important to
recognize and really contributes to that
increasing rental cost
is the um is the vacancy rate and we
have an extraordinarily low
vacancy rate in new hampshire we've been
on this
sort of trend as you can see for a
number of years
and have been below both what what is
generally identified as a balanced
market level which is about five percent
and below what people would describe as
turnover rate which is about three
percent
for a number of years last year we
actually that is 2019 we actually hit
um a a really low point under one
percent
in 2020 the number bounced back a little
bit uh we think partly
because of pandemic related issues and
partly because of some new production in
the southern part of the state
but the reality here is that our vacancy
rate is extremely low which means
it's a very tight market there's a lot
of competition for rental units
and it continues to to press uh prices
upward
dean what do you mean by turnover rate
turnover rate turnover means really the
notion that units aren't really vacant
it is um
the time it takes to move somebody out
and perhaps
um fix up a unit a little bit and move
somebody in
so the unit might be vacant for um days
or even a couple of weeks while that
goes on
representative but it's not really a
vacancy in the context that
um you know the unit is vacant and
people are trying to rent it
thank you um and so turnover rate really
means for all intents and purposes there
is no vacancy um
moving to the next slide i guess ben to
really focus on and the next one
um the focus on really what you asked us
to talk about which is a for sale market
we're going to start really by talking
about closed
sales really the volume of sales
activity and we're
showing you three years worth of data
spread out over the over a six-month
cycle and
part of the reason we gave you only six
months of 2020 is because
there really are two stories for 2020.
the first half of the year
had some impact in the spring associated
with the pandemic when there was kind of
like a forced
um reduction in sales activity because
of the stay-at-home order
and other related factors once that kind
of
changed and we got into mid-summer the
volume of sales
increased significantly and as you can
tell from that light blue bar
um the sales activity in 2020 was was
higher
and virtually every month for the second
half of the year than it was in either
of the previous two years
what's really interesting here is is the
numbers for october
and november and especially december
when sales activity tends to slow down
traditionally
um in the for sale market and really
that did not happen
in a significant sense in 2020 and i
think most realtors would tell you that
the end of last calendar year was much
stronger than
they are historically um used to seeing
um sales activity in december of 2020
was actually
26 percent higher than the year before
which in turn was substantially higher
than the year before that
so showing a very strong market a lot of
demand
for what housing is actually available
in um
with that level of demand um and we'll
look at inventory in a moment
comes upward pressure on pricing and
that's pretty
straightforward here the little squiggly
bluish line
um shows prices month to month and there
is some
seasonality and variability that goes on
because of that
but if you look at the overall trend
line which is the gold if you will or
yellow
dotted line you can tell that purchase
prices have been
trending upward upward pretty
consistently since about 2013.
um and in december of 2020 we hit a new
peak
for median purchase price particularly
in the winter time
frame of 340 000
which was about a 17 increase over the
same time
last year um
one of the motivating factors one of the
contributing factors to this
is again a supply problem um
not unlike the rental side of the market
inventory
of of homes for sale is extremely low it
has been trending downward
uh for what is now basically of 12 or 14
years the black line shows total
listings
on the market um the the teal or or blue
line
is listings under 300 000 we use that as
a
kind of a benchmark for entry-level
uh housing because one of our focus
points as an organization
is first-time buyers and helping them
get in the market
and and the orange line is
listings that are over hundred thousand
dollars
you will note a couple of points there
uh first listings overall
are continuing to decline secondly that
listings
um below three hundred thousand three
hundred thousand and below
um crossed if you will with the ones
above that number
in early 2019 for the first time in this
this trend line of over 14 years um and
both continue to decline so the number
of units available for sale
is is very limited and there's a lot of
demand for them they
turn very fast if you go to the next
slide ben
we can see that um even more starkly
which is
in terms of inventory so in the for sale
market inventory
is described in terms of months
of inventory meaning how long would it
take to
sell all of the units that are on the
market at the current
pace of sales if no new units were to be
added to the market and you can see that
again there's some seasonality to it
but the reality is that once we get into
um it is relatively flat and it is
showing a
inventory of about one month really
depending on whether you're looking at
again um under 300
000 or over 300 000 or the total market
um i think anybody in the real estate
business will tell you that a one month
inventory of homes for sale is
extraordinarily low it is outside
anyone's
experience in recent memory um and it
really means that
literally most homes go on the market
they sell within 30 to 45 days
there is enormous competition for what
is on the market and that does have the
effect of pushing up prices
as we saw earlier next slide ben now one
of the contributing factors to this
um is also very low interest rates and
i think everybody's aware that mortgage
interest rates are
extremely low they are at historic low
levels
um january the 2.73 is an is an index of
uh takes a variety of different sources
and and looks at it it's
really the rate that uh for a 30-year
fixed rate that someone with good credit
uh would be able to access
um but there are rates out there
depending on the term
of a loan that you want to take as low
as around two percent and perhaps
topping out into the mid to high threes
but the reality is that all of those
rates are extraordinarily low compared
to
historic rates so one of the factors
here is that
it has increased in that context
affordability
prices are going up so that reduces
affordability but
interest rates are down and that
mitigates that effect a little bit
but it also is encouraging people to buy
a home
because they're looking at an
opportunity to lock in a very low
interest rate
in this environment that they may not
see again um
in their experience uh next slide then
please
i did want to um perhaps
um share this information with you
though because i think it's a
it's an unknown um and and i you know i
don't really know what the implications
of this are going to be
for the mortgage markets for the sales
markets going forward as we go into the
year this is delinquency data obviously
it's national data but
we can tell you that new hampshire's
data is very similar it's a little
better
but not dramatically better than these
numbers
um and what this really represents is a
really significant uptick in delinquency
as we got into 2020
um but it's important to keep in mind
that it's probably not
real delinquency what do i mean by that
in
about a year ago in march of last year
congress passed the cares act as you
recall and
one of the elements of that was a
provision that said that that um
mortgage holders who had a loan that had
some connection to the federal
government meaning
fannie mae loans freddie mac loans uh
fha
and ginny may and short loans could ask
for uh forbearance meaning deferral of
their mortgage payment
uh for between six and 12 months uh
simply by saying that they had a
covet-related issue
that impacted their ability to pay
without any sort of additional
proof or validation um and a number of
people across the country have taken
advantage
of that provision um technically they
are
delinquent because their mortgage
payments are not being made
even though it's not a traditional form
of delinquency
and you'll note with that blue line
there that
is particularly high among fha
related loans which is the federal
housing administration's guarantee
program which tends to
target first-time buyers and
lower-income
buyers perhaps relative to others but
even for all
categories to cause the significant
uptick
in apparent delinquencies we don't
really know what the implications of
this are going to be over the next 12
months and you may actually have heard
read yesterday and today that the
federal government
decided to extend the ability for people
to
request this forbearance um or deferral
situation
once again so that was slated to end at
the end of march they have now
um extended it through the end of june
um and also allowed people that have
already requested
forbearance uh to extend their
forbearance period
um even further so the question here is
what happens
when folks who are in forbearance reach
the end of that
allowed period the system is
theoretically structured
so that people will either begin paying
again
or will go through some kind of a loan
modification process that allows them to
continue to pay on their loans
and get back into a current situation
um and if that all works the way it is
theoretically supposed to
there might be very little impact on our
markets
if on the other hand uh what we find at
the other end of this is that there's a
lot of economically distressed home
buyers
who can't modify their loans and
continue to stay in their home
then you might see some impact on the
market
that could include increased foreclosure
activity which tends to um impact
consumer
confidence perhaps depressed prices um
but at the same time increase inventory
for sale which would be
something that could help moderate that
challenge in our state and
i really am not in a position we're not
really in a position to predict
um what the implications of all of this
are going to be there are some
experts who believe that it could be
well into 2022
before this issue is fully resolved and
we really understand what the
implications are
for the overall market
high level of forbearance yes sir
the numbers that you use the 11.19
for the fha is that percent
of total loans yes and then
you have any idea what the total loans
are
uh the total number of loans this is
national data
but we can get the committee data on new
hampshire
um the total number of more i would
point out a couple of things this
the the federal forbearance rules only
apply to federally
uh connected loans which amount to about
of all mortgages nationally and we think
about 65 or 66 percent of all mortgages
in new hampshire
but we can get you a breakdown on that
um i don't have it with me right now but
we can get you that and we'll send that
along
to chris for the committee um i would
also tell you that we believe based on
our own
analysis of our portfolio that the real
delinquency rate here
is about half the number that you're
looking at in other words
those that are that are true what we
would describe as traditionally
delinquent
probably are in the five or six percent
range for
um for fha loans at this point um and
the rest are those people that took
advantage of this deferral
opportunity but may not have any
significant difficulty
as things come out what we're hearing is
that
about 25 of everyone who
begins the transition out of forbearance
has significant challenges um
and the other 75 are able to resume
payments but um still early to know
um exactly what the implications of this
are going to be for our overall markets
next slide please ben
[Music]
going back to the question of why are we
experiencing such a tight market
environment why is there such an
inventory shortage
um we frankly aren't building enough
housing this is not a new
story we've talked about this i think
with the committee in the past i know a
couple of years ago i spoke
with many of you and and really went
over some of this data and i remember
russ tebow has spoken to the committee
in the past and
he did some analysis for us that
concluded that you know there's
somewhere between a 15 and 20
000 unit shortage in new hampshire
between what we believe is true demand
versus the availability of housing both
in the multi and single family side
these two lines represent building
permits um
the black or gray line is single-family
housing permits the sort of orangey line
is um multi-family permits you can see
the
effect of the great procession 2008-9
the dramatic drop-off in building
activity particularly on the
single-family side
nowhere near full recovery there we're
about half
the level of activity not even there
that we were before the great recession
and
multifamily has seen a little bit of
recovery but
not um enough frankly to meet what we
view as being a
current consumer demand so we're simply
not producing enough housing
to meet a demand and that puts pressure
on the markets
um the the positive side of that is it
means if you're trying to sell a house
you can sell it quickly
if you're a landlord you can fill your
vacancies quickly um
it also means that prices are continuing
to go up which if again if you're
selling a house is a good thing
uh it's not as good if you're trying to
buy one and and
from an affordability perspective it
creates challenges for people
there was a specific question that we
were asked to try to address which is
whether there
is um been any substantive increase in
the number of people
out of state purchasing homes in new
hampshire
and we have been looking at that issue
because we know there's been some
speculation in the media about this
there's been some anecdotal
conversation about this um so we went
back and took a look at this over the
last month or two
and look back at a data going back as
far as 2016.
you will note that it was pretty steady
um through
up until 2020 that about um 75
of all of the home purchases in new
hampshire were by
from people who were already here uh
about
15 were from people from massachusetts
which is where most people who migrate
into the state from another
part of the country come from um and one
percent was
uh people from the rest of the country
um there was an uptick in 2020 there's
no doubt about it
um the the number of new hampshire-based
buyers dropped to 71
and the number of massachusetts based
buyers went up
to 18 although the number from the rest
of the country didn't really change much
uh hard to know whether that is a
beginning of a significant
trend that will impact the markets long
term
um or whether that was just a sort of a
blip that was directly related to the
pandemic there is
a theory um which is you know not
necessarily
derived scientifically but is simply
based on anecdotal
information that some folks from
massachusetts have chosen
to purchase homes in new hampshire
because of the lower density the less
urban environment
as a result of their experience during
the the pandemic
the impact appears to have been more
heavily concentrated again based on
anecdotal information
in the seacoast in the lakes region in
the north country
and may involve circumstances in which
people are acquiring properties that
would otherwise be seasonal homes and
essentially converting them
into permanent residences um hard to
know
something we will continue to watch and
we will continue to report on
as things evolve but this is the data
that we have
at this point there is is a small but
subtle
change in this phenomenon in this
dynamic
next slide ben um
so trends in terms of sales activity
just summarizing very strong demand
fueled i think by a combination of low
inventory
and low interest rates uh people see an
opportunity to purchase at low rates
they see
houses limited number of houses for sale
and they move quickly to buy them
and that sort of has enhanced the demand
in the second half of 2020
causing those sort of um normal
rates of sales even as we got into the
winter months
time on market is very short um and
prices have been
being pressed upward um as a result of
these factors
um it is in fact as i mentioned earlier
really a tale of two years the first
part of 2020 was
not that strong but the second part was
very very strong
and as we come into 21 it appears um
just anecdotally that those trends have
continued
but it's hard to know whether they will
continue as we come out of the pandemic
um next slide ben
the other specific question chris asked
us to uh look at
was the types of mortgages that uh
people were using to the extent that we
were able to
um to glean that information and we
we had to use data from the mortgage
bankers association the national
mortgage bankers association
but this is foreign new hampshire so um
the um first of all the very low
interest rates means that the vast
majority of mortgage activity in the
state now
is for refinancing uh rather than for
purchase
and it's 80 of all loan applications
were
refi um and but there still
reflects a the data still reflects a
significant increase in activity
both purchase and refinance relative to
you can see those numbers there they're
quite significant um
the um we did
look at investor um purchase mortgages
that is people buying homes
for um rental or to to
future resale um new hampshire's numbers
are slightly higher than the national
average there
uh to be honest we don't have good
historic data there to know whether
that's a
new thing or whether that's always been
the case we do know on the second home
side
that new hampshire has tended to have a
slightly higher level
of second home um purchases than
of the national data and that simply
reflects a lot of the destinations we
have that are
sort of seasonal vacation related areas
again the seacoast lakes region
the north country and that's not a new
phenomenon
um in terms of um the types of mortgage
structures that people are choosing
most people are choosing fixed rate
mortgages
um and that makes complete sense if you
can get a mortgage in the three percent
or lower rate you would presumably want
to lock that in
for the longer term about 92 percent of
purchase mortgages are still 30-year
fixed rate
um more refined mortgages are
very excuse me are for shorter terms 15
20 years
again that makes sense people look at
the refinancing not only to save money
but to perhaps shorten the term of their
mortgage and the amount of interest
they're going to have to pay
what is clear here is that adjustable
rate mortgages
are not particularly popular in this
current interest rate environment which
again
a couple of other trends that we would
just note for
the committee the
[Music]
level of population growth in new
hampshire
while not as large as we have
experienced
in previous decades is still higher than
what we're seeing in the rest of the
northeast and i think it reflects
movement again primarily from
massachusetts um
and and probably reflects interest in
really the lifestyle
um other factors that are positive while
maintaining the proximity to
the boston metro area um and
so we are seeing a phenomenon where
there is some
in migration from other states
particularly from massachusetts
um which is not kind of common to the
rest of the northeast
where what population growth is seen
there is largely
from real immigration if you will
outside of the
country um there is also some sense that
there might be some population impact
from people who have traditionally been
seasonal residents that is they already
own
um a property in new hampshire that was
a seasonal property
but they're choosing to move here and
use that as their permanent
or primary residence and again part of
that may simply reflect
um people's retirement planning and
that's always
been true part of it may reflect the
pandemic
because again there's some evidence
nationally that people are choosing to
move
away from urban environments um into
less urban environments
if they can do so and there are some
implications obviously
um in for local population levels and
perhaps demand for services from this
although as we point out there could be
an impact on
on education costs a lot of the folks
who are likely
moving here um do not have
very large households even in the 25 to
40 year range
national data shows that household sizes
have shrunk significantly
and i think there may be one or two more
slides
and then i'll i will take whatever
questions i can um
so just in conclusion right now there's
very high demand
sales activity remains brisk we believe
that will continue
at least in the near term um that will
probably mean that
prices will continue to be forced upward
um
the core issues here again are the
unknowns associated with
foreclosure uh could that increase as a
result of
economic distress and we won't know that
until the whole forbearance
issue unwinds and that could take um
at least a year quite frankly um and and
the constrained supply
remains a significant concern in new
hampshire both
for sale and for rental housing and the
very last slide just points out that
um that there are implications
from that for economic growth um in the
future
uh for the state we've talked about this
uh in the past um
if businesses can't recruit and retain
people because they don't have a place
to live
that's a real challenge even in this
environment where remote
working has has increased dramatically a
lot of
the kind of job growth that we want to
encourage is in places like
manufacturing and
people need to physically be here in
most cases for that to work
um and that means they need to have a
place to live somewhere
um near their their job there is an
affordability challenge here which we
always point out it's our job
um and and some threat to housing
stability particularly for lower income
people because
of that very limited supply and the
upward pressure on prices
and with that i'll stop talking at you
and try to answer your questions and if
um you'd like us to go back to a slide
just tell us and
i have no idea how to do that but i'm
sure that ben will be able to figure it
out
thank you dean and welcome sir
thank you mr chair um thank you for your
presentation very good
uh i do want you to go back to your side
uh slide six
there it is yes i just want to clarify
to make sure the uh
uh did the orange line that's the
12 month moving average is that it
yes sir okay the average of the last 12
months
after it's recalculated correct yes sir
yeah just to show a trend line because
the
there's so much volatility in the month
to month
numbers traditionally in fact if you
look at it going
it's not so much now obviously but if
you go back
there used to be these sort of low
points in the winter time
when there was less demand and prices
tended to bottom out so we've always
tried to show the
12-month moving average to really give
people a sense of what
price trends are like right now i
appreciate the moving average actually
so i just have a comment i don't want to
make sure my wife and i were coming back
from
breakfast the other day and i said you
know there was a new development in
august that was they were just putting a
road in in my town
and this was the end of august 18 plots
uh they are all of them are sold but
three
and most of them are already up in the
span of like five months
it's unbelievable and they're all
gigantic houses because we have a two
two acre zoning so the builders are
going to want to build something big on
those
so it's just amazing i was just shocked
at how quickly they got these homes up
i just i think yes sir i think that
anecdotally
both builders and realtors will tell you
that
particularly new construction there is
enormous demand for it and if
anything that is built will sell very
quickly
and to go to your point about larger
more expensive homes
through a combination of factors the
cost of labor the availability of labor
the custom materials
and frankly regulatory policies as you
pointed out the two-acre minimum
uh issue you know it pushes
the market in the direction of higher
cost housing when there is an
opportunity for new construction
can i have one uh follow-up question uh
yeah uh back to your uh the first or
your second slide or third slide i guess
was on the uh
reynolds you mentioned some southern
markets there were some
is that more in the salem area
londonderry
that region where that would it's
basically a
southern rockingham and hillsborough
counties is where we've seen
the increased activity londonderry is a
particular example
frankly of where there's been a lot of
multi-family development
also to a degree merrimack to a degree
bedford
um i'm counting really kind of
manchester south
if you will in that that sort of broad
stroke
well do you are you familiar with
rockingham park's uh
development there i know a lot of those
are condominiums but are some of those
rentals as well
it i am not um i'm not
super familiar with it but my
understanding is that
there is mostly condominium there may be
some rental housing in there but i
believe it's fairly high
and housing yep okay
thank you you're welcome before we go to
the new
questions on the current listing slide
on each line like the bottom line the
orange line
does that represent sales under 3 100
yes sir yeah i'm sorry i realized that
we should have put
little notes on what this meant or a key
i apologize
uh the black line is total listings
of the the blue line is listings under
000 and the orange line is listings
over three hundred thousand dollars
thank you representative army
thank you mr chairman i don't know why
the top thing at least on mine
is is turning between various people
really quickly and being very
distracting
it stopped it now that i'm there but
i had several questions about housing
permits lagging
and where are the buyers coming from
which is kind of late
in the slideshow they've dropped
age numbers at that point
yeah and um the first one
is there doesn't seem to be
any real increase in construction going
on in 2020
and i think that's probably due
to to the regulatory
part that you were talking about plus in
my
area in lebanon we have almost a
thousand units
of apartments which have been uh
permitted or almost completely permitted
and two one of them permitted in one of
them almost
are which are i think 800 units between
them
uh have been um on they've got lawsuits
against them
so that's going to take a while i don't
know if they can go to the housing court
um but then eventually
these almost certainly are going to be
built
um and they're feeding
and my other question about that graph
was whether the
why it is that multi-family housing
still
isn't being built very much is it does
it cost
i think it is primarily
a regulatory issue in that in order
and although it does connect to your
question representative about cost
in order to build multi-family housing
efficiently you need scale and in order
to get
to scale you need a regulatory
environment that
is supportive of that scale and that's
really
present only in sort of limited places
so
there are parts of the seacoast again
the southern tier
that we discussed earlier certain
specific communities that have made a
really concerted effort to try to
provide opportunities for that type of
housing development
that's where you're seeing it in other
parts of the state
it is not as easy to do it's also true
quite frankly and
to be i think respectful of folks that
in certain market areas you can't be
sure that you'd be able to get the
market to build at the scale that would
allow you to
um do it efficiently um the one that you
mentioned the upper valley is one where
there's a lot of demand
and you can get to scale um it's but
it's kind of unique
yes thank you and if i could
thank you mr chairman um
i think the metaphor of the
uh k-shaped recovery is extremely
interesting
uh the diverging where have seem to get
stronger and have nots weaker
and we tend to think of those in
aggregated demographic
terms but i wonder how much you've
disaggregated the data here
down into at least counties if not even
communities
even in the upper valley as was just
mentioned by
representative army where there's demand
in lebanon
30 minutes south in charlestown i can
point to one subdivision of 24 lots
i think very fairly priced that
was divided about a dozen years ago
and in a dozen years three lots of sold
so we have a very very different picture
i think in sullivan county than in the
rest of the state
and in my town uh even
relative to sullivan county most
information that we ever see is
aggregated
at federal and state level and it
doesn't give us the insights
into the way geography is part of the
i don't disagree with any of that i do
believe you're absolutely right and we
should we tend to show data a
statewide or a really broad region and
it has a certain story you are correct
that there are certain markets
that do not reflect uh perhaps
some of the characteristics here um
and um those markets
may have slightly higher um
of inventory for instance of for sale
homes
it may take longer to sell a home in
those markets
and their price appreciation may not be
quite as dramatic we do
try to do that when we can one of the
challenges we run into sometimes
is statistical significance when there's
a small
volume of data that we can work with
i would point out that we do publish
vacancy rates
and rent levels by county and
the data there from last year anyway and
we'll be redoing that that analysis in
the next few months
did not show significant difference
across the state i mean the rent levels
might be lower
in some markets but there were not
dramatic
changes in vacancies when we actually
looked at those at least on the rental
side
of the market but i agree with you that
there is there are market areas that do
not reflect
these specific factors as strongly as
others
absolutely right very quick follow is if
you
have any information uh
that would allow you to give us the same
information that you have in these
slides on a county basis i think that
would be very revealing
we will do the best we can with that
yeah
representative i can follow up with you
directly with
the some of the data that we're able to
disaggregate
on say a county basis uh or in some
cases smaller geographies but as as dean
pointed out
where we're dealing with data on a at a
town level
we start to witness um significant
margins of error
unless we're looking at absolute numbers
as we do with
the building permit data for example
understood thank you welcome mary
hack and phillips thank you mr chair
as a side note before i direct my
question to the housing finance
authority mr chair i thought it might be
helpful
um i mean this picture of the
residential market has been really
eye-opening and i think it will be
helpful for us but i'm wondering if it's
possible to get
some sort of commercial data at all for
the state
um and i'm not sure who we would direct
that request to but i just thought maybe
i would
chris okay
let's talk about how we can get that
information
yep okay thank you
um and then my question to you um
well to the housing finance authority um
it's just a follow-up on your
quick discussion about those mortgage
delinquencies and
you know the unknown kind of situation
related to those mortgage payment
deferrals and forbearance
um forbearances that are being taken
care of by
elect i should say elected by certain
homeowners
if this uh situation is kind of going to
unfold into 2022-ish
time zone um is it is it your
understanding as well that there is
sort of a backup in terms of
foreclosures and bankruptcies that
homeowners are pursuing
in you know the current market and do
you anticipate a similar
um kind of pent-up demand for those as
i cannot speak with any definitive sense
because i
as i said i think there's a lot of
unknowns about how this process is going
to
unfold um there have been
very little on the way of foreclosures
as you know because of either moratoria
or because
of this forbearance structure um
for almost a year now and um
30 of all the mortgages in the state are
not covered by the federal rules
um you know the they are mostly in the
hands of
community banks and credit unions who
have portfolioed them and my
understanding is that most of them have
been
providing essentially the same kind of
protections to their borrowers that the
federal government
has been providing whether they can and
will continue to do that indefinitely
is is a good question um i
would suspect that there will be some
increase in foreclosure activity
eventually as this shakes out simply
because it seems unlikely that
all or you know the vast majority of
people
will be able to adjust their mortgages
if they really had any kind of
significant economic impact
but it isn't unknown and i don't want to
mislead the committee by saying i know
that that's going to happen
i would imagine the bankruptcies will
also go up if that happens because
that's one of the tools that people use
as you know to um to
you know react to a potential
foreclosure
if if the system works the way everybody
hopes it works
then people will go through a loan
modification process
um the again that low interest rate
environment helps
because it means that you can take a
loan that was written at say six percent
and you can restructure it to say three
percent um and maybe save people quite a
bit of money and adjust for a drop in
their
economic circumstance and keep them in
their home and i think that's the goal
of the federal government in all of
these programs and i suspect it's the
goal of most lenders
uh but we really don't know until this
all kind of
uh comes through and
the continued um pushing forward
of forbearance just kind of keeps
pushing forward the
answer to your question to be honest i'm
and
and i i wish i had a better answer for
you than that this is a
just a high level of uncertainty that
all of us in the industry are
just living with right now um and if i
may i'll just speak to your earlier
question i can't answer your your
question about commercial
data but one of the things we have
decided that we're going to do in
partnership with the community
development finance authority is
commission
um a study of the
vacant commercial properties that might
have the
um opportunity to be converted into
housing
as a way of of sort of addressing that
that inventory issue that we talked
about earlier
and that's something we hope to have by
this summer
my question is is there any historical
data that you might be able to share
with us about um foreclosures and
bankruptcies
or you know lobbying that into the
foreclosure um just so we could kind of
see
possibly what the trend was for the last
few years and if there is
you know foreseeable bottleneck um or
dropbox yeah
i'm sorry we have we have very good data
on foreclosures going back over a decade
um that we can share with you and i can
tell you that the trend was
a very very much downward over the last
few years
we were projecting a very limited number
of foreclosures for 2020 originally
before the pandemic hit and
obviously there were very few but that
was an artificial
dynamic and we don't really know where
it would have ended up
we will look at the bankruptcy
information i don't know
whether we have access to that but if we
can get it we'll get it to you
thank you representative tucker
representative
thank you mr chairman uh first if i may
just
um answer representative obrami's
question
about um rockingham park
in salem being from salem i am familiar
there are
uh several rental units being built
um as well as as housing the rental
units are quite expensive
they seem to be way above the chart that
the average that we saw in the chart
here which i believe was fourteen
hundred and something for
two bedrooms i believe two bedrooms are
more closer to the three thousand dollar
range there
obviously there's several factors that
are leading to a tight housing market
and low inventory
low interest rates and so forth that
you've mentioned um
how do we have a sense for how big a
factor
covet is in the sense that um
many people are reluctant to list their
houses because
with covert they don't want to go around
and look at houses
look at other houses or they're not sure
uh so
if if covid gets to a point where people
aren't
uh people are much more confident that
it's under control and
and you know people are vaccinated
whatever do we anticipate that that's
a fairly big factor in in
increasing inventory i think it's a very
good question
and one that i wish i had a really good
answer to i think anecdotally
people do believe that is people in the
industry do believe there are there is
uh
inventory there that would um come on
the market
if people were more comfortable um in
this environment with people coming into
their homes
the the one factor that i i guess i
would reinforce
is that there's not a lot of new
production
and so um we're still going to have
potentially a shortage
it might mitigate a little bit the the
very tight inventory situation that
we're currently
experiencing and you might see a little
more um a product available if
if we get through the pandemic um and
people have a higher level of comfort
going forward you're probably right
about that
it's just it's very difficult to gauge
um in this environment there are those
frankly who
um would have predicted six or seven
months ago that there would have been
very little sales activity in the second
half of 2020 for exactly the reason
you're
discussing yet as you know from the data
there was
more than anybody anticipated um so it's
sometimes hard to predict consumer
behavior to be
honest with you um but likely is not it
will go up
when people are more comfortable and
just to be
clear on the rent number the number that
we show is
is a median so 50 of everything is above
and 50
below theoretically um so you're
absolutely right there's a lot of
much higher priced rental housing in the
market than
that chart would indicate i brought the
slide back
up because as dean indicated before
the second half of the year in 2020 uh
it completely overcame the shortfall in
sales in the first half of the year
and i think that this demonstrates um
the adjustment that realtors in
particular have made
in marketing homes so we have a lot more
virtual marketing if you will
where potential buyers don't have to
enter the home
maybe only when uh they're ready to
um you know make an offer uh would they
be interested
and um you know they've developed other
means of showing homes as well
and you know i think open houses while
the
occupants are away also helps to allay
some of people's concerns about covet
so that the numbers of sales that we've
seen
in is particularly in november december
and going into january
are uh in stark contrast to typical
winter trends
the pace of sales remains very strong
yeah i would just reinforce quickly
ben's point there i think the industry
like a lot of other industries um
reacted
and and evolved very quickly and came up
with protocols designed to
hopefully mitigate a lot of people's
concerns about things and
and they've managed to support a really
astounding level of sales
during this very difficult period
uh thank you mr chair um ribs and ramy
triggered something in my memory here
from a couple of months ago
hearing about dartmouth hitchcock uh
going to build some workforce housing on
their campus
um uh i'd like to represent all me to
weigh in a minute about that as well but
i thought that's still going on but are
there other businesses that you know of
that are
are moving in this direction to build
some workforce housing on their
on their land many companies own a lot
of land that they can build something
like this without having to incur
the cost of the land uh that they
already own
um can you just weigh in on that yeah
it's an interesting question it's one
that we um engage
uh folks about uh fairly regularly
i think the direct answer to the
question i am not aware
of any significant number of cases where
companies are actually doing that
dartmouth hitchcock
is um probably a leader in that context
um but again to be honest with you i can
recall having conversations with people
there about this idea um almost three
years ago and it
took them a while to sort of get to the
point where they were comfortable with a
role
um it is you really are asking um
you know businesses to fundamentally
rethink what their role is
relative to the housing of their
employees
and it takes folks a while to kind of
move in that direction
um and um it tends to first be of
interest and this is a national
um trend um for what i would describe as
sort of
place fixed employers employers that
really
you know are institutions like a health
care facility or an educational facility
that doesn't really have a choice but to
um
have to stay in one location and they
can't
expand somewhere else um in another
state or another you know
market area in an easy way we've seen
some evidence of healthcare institutions
in particular
being leaders in this role and we're
actually part of a group
working with some other partners to look
at how we could encourage healthcare
institutions to um to do more of that
um but obviously they're a little
distracted right now by other
factors and perhaps this is not their
highest priority in other cases
to follow up mr chair yeah just just a
comment again
uh when you were mentioning uh
repurposing uh commercial properties
and maybe if representative molloy is on
this on the zoom i can't see his name
here but
he can weigh in i remember hearing a
couple people called me and i never
verified
that our small mall that we have in
newington
is going to be closing and going to
become uh
resident they're going to make they're
going to convert it into residential
uh apartments uh so i don't know if
you folks have heard anything about that
but maybe representative
who lives in the same neighborhood i do
uh one town apart we're
we're kind of the suburbs of uh of
portsmouth
um whether that is actually going to
happen
and i know you are aware of some of this
yes
so we're we're aware that the the
newington planning board
uh commissioned a study by planning
consultants
um to look at alternative uses of the
property
um and not that not that the planning
board controls the use of the property
but
they do have a direct impact on the
zoning
and i believe that the the newington
planning board is
looking at potential zoning changes to
accommodate
a wider variety of uses that would
include some residential uses for that
property
yeah i can understand the difficulty
there there's only 700 citizens in
newington
and a lot of malls and other businesses
so they they have a pretty good tax rate
i'm sure they're going through the uh
thought process of uh what does more
more residential property mean in terms
of their schools and all that
but all right thank you so you're
confirming what i what i thought i heard
thank you
just to expand upon one thing that the
dean was
talking about in response uh
representative
rami uh we are familiar with a
uh the owners of a long-term care
facility
in durham harmony homes which is in the
process of building
their their own general contractor
building a i think a 40 plus unit
development
in dover and this is a kind of a cottage
style development small homes on the
order of four to five hundred square
feet each
uh that would be for the employees
of uh the long-term care facility so
they would
occupy these units and it would be
dedicated for their uses this is going
through the permitting
process right now uh in in the city of
dover
thank you i appreciate that reminding me
of that that is um
another example though what i was
speaking to earlier which is a place
based
business if you will they they really
you know they they're in
a particular market they really don't
have a choice but to have employees
in that market and they therefore they
have taken that major step to actually
move into the role of being a housing
developer
in order to address the need thank you
representative thank you mr chairman
on i'd like to start by saying something
more about
on dartmouth college and dartmouth
hitchcock dartmouth college has been
in the business of creating housing for
its employees
since at least the 1960s which is when
my parents moved in
and we um from the
the upper valley housing coalition that
began i think 20 years ago now
and we canceled it because we had
achieved our objective of getting people
to
believe in affordable housing in our
region on
we had um we
we were after dartmouth hitchcock to do
similarly
since 20 years ago and it's taken that
long for them
to get to this point but also that land
that i
i am pretty sure that it's i know that
it's not their land that they are
intending on
building on because they'd have to get
the zoning changed and that would be a
fight
because their land has a lot of valuable
green space
and people get upset at them
and a lot of animals that live on it
presently
so um they are building on right next to
their land on and bought a plot that had
been
uh i think up for sale actually for a
very long time
and um they're the ones that are
threatened currently and now i think
that they're already under a lawsuit
uh that's delaying them but
um they they are almost certain to
get permission to do that in the future
what the terms of their contract they
found the contractor they helped design
everything on i don't know maybe the
hanover
people also know something about this
but on
what the terms their contract are and
how much they're actually putting into
it aside from technical help
on as versus the contractor himself i'm
not sure
i don't see anybody else so thank you
dean and ben that was an
excellent presentation i'm sorry could i
i had another question which i forgot in
answering that one could i ask him
yeah thank you
i'm wondering if foreclosures
are more going to be more attractive to
lenders
than uh trying to renegotiate as we're
coming out of this
because there is high demand in the
market
and they can sell them quickly back
after the great recession
they were stuck with places they'd
foreclosed on for years
and they tried not to foreclose quite
frequently because of that
um because they couldn't get rid of them
so we had one in my complex
and it took two years before somebody
wouldn't couldn't that be a factor or do
you have some reasons
that you think would mitigate against
that well
i i think that generally most lenders
would prefer not to foreclose i mean it
is a complicated and expensive
process there are there's risks of
litigation
there's a lot of factors that that play
there
you are right that the market dynamics
now are very different than they were
10 years ago and and one of the factors
that
that does has to be taken into
consideration is how easily will you
resell
a property if you take it back um again
i point out that 70
of or 68 or something like that of the
loans in new hampshire
are federally supported and so the those
institutions are really deciding
in the end um what the path will be to
unravel things for those those problems
and i i suspect that the the policy sort
of directive there will be to try to
avoid foreclosure if it is
at all possible um for the remaining 30
um i can't speak to be honest i would
think that most lenders again would
prefer to work with an existing borrower
if they can and given low interest rates
in many cases they should be able to
modify loans
um but there there probably will be some
circumstances in which that's just not
possible
and you might see a little bit of an
uptick in foreclosures
at some point um down the road but
again you know up till now most lenders
are being very supportive of
um i think their clients the one
space where there might be a unique
challenge
is manufactured housing um
because um most manufactured housing
units
are not eligible for the federal
protections because they were not
financed with mortgages that have those
federal attachments to them if you will
and so if there's a sort of a small
subset that could be
at higher risk it would likely be
manufactured
housing much of which is uh financed
by what i would describe as
non-traditional
lenders that is not local banks or
or credit unions but by sort of national
entities that focus
principally on manufactured housing and
i guess if there was going to be a
a segment of the market i would really
worry about
it would be that segment um as we come
out of this and i can't predict
how that will go but that would be one
that i would be concerned about
would i have a follow-up with the
i think it's a third of the manufactured
housing in new hampshire now
is in cooperatives that are
uh the guardian is the new hampshire
uh charitable loan fund and you're
absolutely
thanks to work with them so you're
absolutely right
and and a lot of banks do that we also
work with them with some fannie mae
products
which basically will provide the same
protections to individuals
but it's really the remaining
um um folks that i would be concerned
about
and we will follow up mr chairman by the
way with uh on the questions we were
asked
ben and i will chat about them make sure
we've got them and we will get the
committee as
what we can in terms of the information
that you asked for
well thank you and thank you for your
presentation
thanks for the opportunity anytime
the next time we meet will be tomorrow
morning starting at nine o'clock
we have six hearings and other carryings
on bills
and we'd like to be able to exec
a number of bills in between these
hearings if it's possible
tomorrow and then thursday
when at nine o'clock we'll meet with the
governor's budget
director to go over the
revenue estimates that the governor has
in his budget
and what and try to determine
what his current law and what has
been put in there for our
[Music]
new taxes or fees
and then at 11 o'clock on thursday we'll
meet with the department of safety
to go over the road toll and a variety
so for i want to remind the republican
members if you didn't receive my link
to the caucus meeting at 2 30 today
let me know and i will re-send it to
them norm can i jump in
yes uh i don't know if you said this i
was kind of split attention there for
the first
20 minutes of the thing did you mention
that tomorrow is a hundred percent
zoom no that we do not have a room oh
yes yes tomorrow is will be 100
zone because at the last moment they did
not have a room
and i volunteered to save them
so and the second thing from uh
one thing that is for everybody from
this morning was the
paul paul smith the clerk wanted
everybody to be reminded to
to pick your lunch off the menu that's
been sent out to everybody
so if you haven't done that look look at
your legislative email there's a
survey of what you know please indicate
what you want for lunch the
anything else from anybody mr chairman
yes representative nunes um i did get
the test
email from you but i did not get the
link from you
um and also i'm presenting a bill at two
o'clock today
uh so i may be late to caucus fine
i'll resend that clear thank you
anything else from anybody on yet yes
from me yes two questions one
the same question i had about tomorrow
uh for thursday
are we not meeting in the afternoon or
are we doing something
there's nothing at this point in time
scheduled for thursday afternoon
unless something comes up okay
and the second one do you have any idea
what they're planning on doing with this
for lunch
i'm trying to go to this but i do not
want to eat
with my mask off for lunch what after
saturday
yeah at the sessions as far as
the choice they've asked you to fill out
what you want i have no idea how we're
going to eat it
was that brought up at the chairman's
meeting this morning uh no it wasn't
it wasn't uh my understanding is we're
going to be spaced
even further apart than uh we were at
the
unh ice hockey rink
so that's something
and i brought a special sandwich that i
could try to eat
also my understanding is that the lunch
is not going to last
that long the period of time because
we have a lot of bills and and um the
first day ends at five
can't run over they have to break down
the room for the event that the evening
the second day we have to break it three
unless that's changed
uh so it's a very limited amount of time
to do all these first committee bills
well they're trying to and we're
starting at nine i guess as well which
major this is chris yes um i know you
you have
bill work until two o'clock on wednesday
but i just want to make the committee
aware if you are done your work
i'm at 2 30 house finance is hearing
from the governor on the budget
and the zoom link is in the calendar so
and your committee's done its work you
may want to just hear
um some of the questions that come from
house finance and you may
um you'll find a friend on finance that
could ask some questions you might have
about some of the changes that are being
proposed
i don't know if we'll be through by 2 30
because it's a pretty busy day tomorrow
but it looks like it in the calendar but
i just
it was more the second part of my
statement you know if there's
somebody on finance you a member wants
to reach out to to maybe
ask a certain question you might have um
there may be an opportunity to do that
and it's probably being recorded
oh